hi there Steve here so it's the holiday
season the Christmas season first of all
let me announce the names of the people
who were the first to send me an email
asking for my book and I signed these
books today and put them in envelopes
and they are on their way to joanne
kelly in san diego gustavo Arroyo in
Puerto Rico Zach Schwartz and wake
forest north carolina Lukesh paw hook
pahud in poland rich banbury in western
australia Kevin oh do in Belfast UK alex
howard in kent UK Trish O'Connor in
Auckland New Zealand Alexander Hardeen
in a chef's coat mood Republic in the
Russian Federation and Matthew Donovan
in ontario canada so those are the 10
people who receive the book I get
individually send an email to everyone
else that was a little bit late and
thank them for their messages many of
them had very kind things to say about
my youtube channel and so forth which I
appreciate and I sent a link to a place
where they can find the e-book and a
place where they could buy the book that
they wanted to buy the book from amazon
and i will leave those same links up
here in the description so as we
approach the holiday you know i think
the thing about the holiday season and
about language learning is always tie
everything to language learning is you
know the opportunity to share things
with others i think that's that's a
wonderful thing that we can do and the
thing about language learning is that it
gives us the opportunity to share
languages and thoughts and stuff with
people all around the world who speak
different languages but who share this
moment
on the planet with us because after all
the history of the world is in millions
of years and here are however many of us
that are on the planet at this time and
the more languages we speak the greater
the opportunity to share things with
other people and sharing is a great
feeling you know i play my old-timers
hockey we had our our last outing
yesterday and then we went for our usual
beer and everybody is very mellow and
then we all send each other email saying
how much we enjoy doing this and so
those are moments that we share um what
else food you know my wife was out doing
her Christmas shopping today and she
knows my back is so sore I don't want to
cook I said okay we're going to go out
so he went to the there's a restaurant
nearby Horseshoe Bay which is a
beautiful location here in West
Vancouver where the ferry boats leave to
Vancouver Island it's a spectacular
scenery and there's an Italian guy who
bought a restaurant there danilo and he
was there in his mum and dad and sister
were visiting from Calabria and they
were all cooking and we had this
absolutely fabulous meal and they
because it's a one-year anniversary they
had 455 canadian dollars four course
meal and with each course you had a
drink you had a Prosecco to start with
you had a glass of red wine with each
course which was the hella rug i had
this clean which is a kind of payment is
a ravioli with pork and beef and rabbit
and then we had I had a slow-cooked pork
and my wife who only had one dish like I
had the whole schmear but she had just
the one dish and then we kind of shared
sharing again and she had duck and both
of these dishes were excellent and then
it had some kind of a souffle dessert
with some amaretto and I might just put
some pictures up of this meal so we were
sharing the meal and then we spoke to
danny low i went back in the kitchen and
spoke to his family in Italian the head
later there is Portuguese so we were
chatting a bit about Portugal and so I
was sharing and of course on Saturday my
son Mark and his family and perhaps his
mother-in-law will come over for dinner
so Karmin my wife is going to be
preparing a dinner but the Flynn were so
good that we have ordered two or
helpings of that as an hors d'oeuvre
that we're going to have and share with
the family on saturday night and then
sunday we go over to mark's house for
Christmas dinner so all of this is about
sharing and I think the holiday season
is not so much about giving gifts in my
opinion but it's about sharing each
other sharing time sharing thoughts
sharing food and so that's the kind of
the season that we're heading into and
so yeah I didn't talk too much about
language learning today but that just
updates you on the whole free book issue
so thank you for listening and go out
and share with your friends and loved
ones during the holiday season buy from